what if you could shrink yourself down
to one millimeter tall about the size of
a frog's egg actually no too many creepy
crawly predators
let's go smaller what if you shrunk to
10 micrometers the size of an animal
cell yeah that's pretty cool but I think
we can go even smaller how about 100
nanometers the size of a virus that's
better but we're not in the mood to be
swallowed by white blood cells so let's
keep going
what if you shrunk to one angstrom the
size of the atom oh-ho yeah I think we
have a winner
if you shrunk to the size of an atom
would it be a fantastic voyage or a
death sentence how would you survive
being shrunk to the atomic level and how
could you pull it off in the first place
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you could shrink to the size
of an atom from Gulliver's Travels to
Alice in Wonderland to ant-man the idea
of shrinking has fascinated us for a
long time the atom in all its splendor
is tiny I mean really really tiny
measuring in at one angstrom to put that
in perspective if you were to blow up an
atom 1 billion times it would only get
as big as a tennis ball while shrinking
seems like it would be an amazing
superpower it would actually be a deadly
fight for survival the first hurdle
you're gonna have to deal with is your
mass if you shrunk without changing your
mass there would be so much compression
that for an ant-sized person the
pressure underneath your tiny feet would
be ten thousand times greater than at
your normal size it would be like a
single ant sized leg pushing down 70
kilograms on each step next you would
have to deal with your body turning
against you your new smaller size will
affect almost every
aspect of your biology for example if
you shrunk to be approximately two and a
half centimeters tall the surface area
of your body through which you lose heat
would decrease about five thousand times
your lung area would be five thousand
times smaller but you could still get
the supply of oxygen you need the way
you extract oxygen from the air is
dependent on the surface area of your
lungs as you get smaller the area of
your lungs is larger than the volume of
your lungs which means there's more than
enough air to go around but you're not
out of the woods yet you'd need to
provide your body with more fuel a lot
more fuel this is because the rate at
which you produce heat is proportional
to the mass of your body the only way to
generate more heat is to increase your
metabolic rate dramatically this means
you have to eat non-stop as the food
needs to be digested in order to produce
heat you'd have to eat as much food as
your body weighs every day just to stay
alive and this is just for the two and a
half centimeter version of you you'll
have even more dangers to face when
you're atom-sized
during your string 'king process you'll
notice the world getting bigger and then
darker it's estimated that if you
decreased in size to approximately one
ten-thousandth of your size the lenses
in your eyes would stop working in just
visible light or that may just be you
passing out when you take the big step
of squeezing your feet into microscopic
shoes one single oxygen molecule will
look like Mount Everest to you yeah
you're literally smaller than an oxygen
molecule how long can you hold your
breath
so if you feel up to the challenge could
you even pull this off the big problem
with shrinking down to the size of an
atom is that the atoms in your body
can't be made any smaller and your body
contains more atoms than the number of
stars we can see in the universe
you'd have to remove some excess baggage
is it possible to remove the atoms in
your body well imagine a mosaic image a
picture made entirely out of smaller
pictures much like these images our body
consists of DNA built up by molecules
consisting of atoms if you started
removing pictures from your mosaic image
you might be able to remove a few and
still see a resemblance to the original
but there is a limit after a while the
image would no longer make sense this is
also true of DNA we might be able to
remove atoms from the molecules building
up the DNA but eventually we'd reach a
limit and make a mess of your human body
so until you solve that problem no
shrinking for you but if you manage to
conquer all the challenges you would be
able to experience the insane world of
quantum mechanics if you could learn to
live in this environment you could have
a blast tunneling and jumping through
impenetrable barriers on your path to
chart the Microverse truth be told
though it's probably easier living at
the size we are mostly because we don't
have to deal with things like giant
spiders but what if that wasn't the case
what if spiders were the size of humans
well that's a story for another